la guerre du vietnam bat son plein
un campement des forces spéciales
américaines est envahi 8 béret vert sont
prises au piège dans un bunker
souterrain
seuls leurs coéquipiers peuvent les
sauver le petit groupe de soldats
élabore une audacieuse opération de
sauvetage
ils devront faire preuve de patience
d'astuces et de courage pour déjouer des
troupes ennemies plus nombreuses et
mieux armé que la vie de huit hommes en
dépend
en cette ère de violence des quatre
coins du globe
une nouvelle race de guerriers n'est
armés jusqu'aux dents et ayant subi une
formation sans pareil ces hommes
d'exception triés sur le volet doivent
remplir des missions secrètes où leur
vie est souvent en jeu voici les
dangereuses missions spéciales de ses
commandos
le 31 janvier 1968 2 vietnam du nord
violent la trêve imposée pour les
célébrations du têt
le nouvel an vietnamien l'armée nord
vietnamienne la nv lancent des attaques
contre plusieurs provinces et villes
importantes du vietnam du sud
à saigon l'ambassade américaine tombe
entre les mains de la nv en moins de 24
heures
juste au sud de la zone démilitarisée la
base de marines américains de khe sanh
et pilonnée par l'artillerie nord qui
est la mienne
les fusillés de la nv réussisse a touché
un dépôt de munitions
l'explosion pulvérise la quasi totalité
des réserves de la base
le président lyndon johnson refuse
d'abandonner ce point stratégique
si la nv s'empare de khe sanh ils
pourront traverser la zone démilitarisée
poursuivre leur incursion jusque dans
les régions peuplées de la côte sud
vietnamiennes les 6600 amis en poste à
quai sans reçoivent l'ordre du président
de se préparer à l'une des plus
importantes batailles de cette guerre le
petit camp de la nv se trouve sur la
route de l'armée nord vietnamienne
les bérets verts qui s'y trouvent en
train de 400 sud vietnamien pour mener
des opérations clandestines
francklin 12,7 à leur opérateur radio
alive et nous devions former autant de
soldats que nécessaire on a commencé par
entraîner une dizaine d'hommes et finit
par an l'entraîné d'emilie
les bérets verts combattent aux côtés
des soldats sud vietnamien de la garde
de la défense civile et régulière
les soldats sud vietnam ir défendent
leur terre et leurs familles contre la
nv
le jour les bérets verts enceintes aux
soldats sud vietnamien les règles de
l'art du combat moderne
la nuit ils patrouillent en territoire
ennemi
nous devions surveiller la frontière
entre le vietnam du nord et le laos et
informer les autorités concernées de
toute infiltration nord vietnamienne
le danger guette les patrouilleurs à
tout moment il risque la capture dans ce
n'est pas la mort le sergent rituel
arles était alors médecin en poste à
l'arrivée chaque jour nous patrouillons
rencontrer des troupes nord vietnamienne
elle était partout pas un jour ne passe
sans qu'il y ait un affrontement avec
live et l'importance stratégique de la
base et la nature clandestine de ces
opérations font de la lgv est une cible
prioritaire pour l'ennemi le lieutenant
pommery a été postée à deux reprises et
est reconnu pour ses missions de
reconnaissance en territoire secret
ennemis live et tenait à éliminer cette
menace
l'offensive du têt s'intensifient les
troupes de la nv convergent sur kessal
la fragilité de la base de la lgv est
inquiète de plus en plus le sergent-chef
john huston en examinant les cartes on
remarque les bases de kiss and puis j'ai
8 61 08 81 nord et sud est finalement
plane veille oui mais elles sont
indiquées en bleu et les positions
ennemies sont en rouge
seuls quelques petits points bleus
étaient noyés dans cette mer de rouge
dans l'éventualité d'une attaque la base
de quais san à la charge de porter
secours aucun de l'arrivée mais que ça
n'est déjà menacé vingt mille soldats
ennemis s'apprête à envahir la base
le camp de limbé est sur le pied
d'alerté
le sergent tente cela patrouillent le
secteur avec des soldats sud vietnamien
dans les eaux de la rivière à répondre
située à quelques kilomètres du camp ils
font une découverte qui changera le
cours de la guerre
woods fender nous avons remarqué des
ponts soumaré à environ 15 cm sous la
surface de l'eau il était fait de roche
s'empiler mais il était assez solide
pour permettre à des véhicules lourds de
traverser dans le son se met à la
recherche de traces
il veut découvrir quels véhicules
empruntent ce pont
sur la rive ils remarquent des
empreintes laissées par un char d'assaut
cette constatation est lourde de sens si
des chars d'assaut viennent dans ce
secteur l'invs et sera certainement
ciblé le camp n'est pas équipé pour
faire face à une attaque blindés à son
retour à l'aube le sergent thomson se
rend immédiatement au centre
d'opérations tactique il est installé
dans un bunker souterrain
il informe le commandant deux camps de
sa découverte
la nouvelle surprend son supérieur le
capitaine franck willoughby en vingt ans
de conflit les nord vietnamiens n'ont
jamais fait usage de chars d'assaut
un bataillon de là aussi un allié arrive
au petit avant-poste de onlive et au
pied de la colline l'adjudant eugene
ashley le sergent reach d'aline deux
médecins des bérets verts dirige le camp
il assure aussi les soins médicaux des
soldats les nouvelles qu'apportent les
laotiens confirme les craintes des
bérets verts j'ai demandé au là aussi
pourquoi il était venu ici
ils m'ont répondu qu'ils avaient été
vaincus par la nv et que ces derniers
avaient des chars d'assaut leurs
vêtements et leurs armes et est encore
intacte aucun d'entre eux n'a été blessé
pas même légèrement
il ne donnait pas l'impression de s'être
battue très longtemps ils ont répété que
les nord vietnamiens étaient nombreux et
qu'ils avaient plusieurs chars
un commandant des forces spéciales
postées à tamagne le colonel daniel
sango est envoyé à l'enlever afin
d'évaluer la situation
selon le lieutenant marc week-ends le
camp ne pouvait repousser une invasion
du blindé ne se basent était protégée
par des barbelés rasoir et des mines
directionnelle clément rien de cela ne
pouvait arrêter un véhicule à chenilles
de ce gabarit
un char d'assaut pouvait passer par
dessus sans le moindre problème
le capitaine nuit au bifff parachuté
sans armes légères antichar à l'arrivée
les m 72 sont des lance-roquettes
expérimentaux tenu à l'épaule ces armes
portatives et jetables sont conçus pour
tirer un seul au but les bérets verts
espère que ses lance-roquettes tiendront
tête au char de la nv
l'invasion nord vietnamiennes se
poursuit et menacent d'engloutir la
levée sur son passage
les bérets verts sont en état d' alerte
dans la nuit du 6 février les fusées
éclairantes disposé autour du camp sont
déclenchés un grondement inquiétant
capte l'attention du capitaine
willoughby du lieutenant watkins le sol
se met soudainement à trembler les
bérets verts sont attaqués
j'ignorais ce qui se passait mais nous
pouvions voir des projecteurs dans les
bois ce qui n'était jamais arrivé
auparavant
la nva avance à un rythme effarant
derrière des chars d'assaut soviétique
d'habitude les nord vietnamiens ont
plutôt recours à des tactiques de combat
de brousse la fusillade seule alerte à
l'avant-poste de onlive et les sergents
ashley et elle ne se met en position
malgré les deux kilomètres qui les
séparent
ils voient que le camp est en difficulté
on entendait les cris de douleur des
soldats enterrés aussitôt par le bruit
des canons et des déflagrations
c'est l'enfer comme celui de dante
dans le bunker les hommes ça ou de m 72
les blés des envahissent le camp le
lieutenant langeree avise la dèche avec
rennes 72 mais il constate qu'il ne
fonctionne pas il craint que les
lance-roquettes n'ait été endommagés
lors du parachutage
seuls ces armes peuvent leur permettre
de contrer l'assaut de la nv finalement
le troisième lance-roquettes qui
l'utilisent fait feu on pouvait
littéralement voir la trajectoire de
l'obuts se dirigeant vers le char dans
un an sifflements mais la recette a
simplement ricoché sur le blindage et
elle est partie dans les airs nous
sommes regardés et nous avons compris
que nous étions dans le pétrin
changeront jamais visé la cabine de
pilotage le char s'est alors arrêté et
la tourelle à pivoter dans notre
direction
il était temps de sortir du bunker
les sergents ashley et aoun assistent
impuissants à l'évasion
les soldats de la base de la iv doivent
obtenir des renforts au plus vite
le 6 février 1968 les chars d'assaut
ennemis attaquent le camp américain de
live est situé à la frontière nord est
du vietnam
sandrine 12 demande des renforts à la
base de marines de khe sanh
le nom de code oak et san et
jacksonville il demande à la base de
kaesong de lancer des fusées éclairantes
afin de pouvoir repérer les chars
d'assaut
j'ai signalé la présence de blindés
ennemis dans le camp et j'ai demandé
d'éclairer le secteur à la communication
a alors été interrompue j'ignore pendant
combien de temps ils m'ont demandé de
décrire les véhicules je ne savais trop
quoi dire j'ai répété qu'il s'agissait
de chars d'assaut et que nous avions
besoin d'éclairage je pense que ça ne ne
croyait pas
au même moment caisse année victimes de
l'une des plus importantes offensives
ennemies de la guerre 3 division
d'artillerie de la nv pilonnent l'abat
jour et nuit jusqu'à ce jour personne
n'a vu les nord vietnamiens utilisé des
chars d'assaut
il est plutôt étrange qui s'en servent
maintenant pour s'emparer de petits
quand les hommes de l'en-v ont
sous-estimé l'ampleur de la tacc nous
étions convaincus qu'il serait facile de
repousser les attaques à l'aide des
lance roquettes
car nous pensions qu'il y aurait deux ou
trois chars d'assaut tout au plus avec
cette manche 11 blindés nord vietnamiens
écrase la défense extérieure due qu'à
l'est m 72 sont défectueux
il était possible d'arrêter
l'envahisseur
il était beaucoup trop nombreux les
blindés avaient pénétré dans le camp
d'autres soldats arrivait par l'arrière
en faisons feu sur nous et nous n'avions
pas l'armement nécessaire pour nous
défendre
enders les soldats nord vietnamiens
s'empare rapidement de la base mais
béret vert sont abattus d'autres sont
faits prisonniers
les troupes sud vietnamiennes sont ici
mais à un rythme affolant 8 béret vert
et quelques sud vietnamien se réfugie
dans le bunker souterrain
ils seront à l'abri du moins pour le
moment
à l'intérieur le capitaine willoughby et
ses hommes tentent de s'organiser
pendant ce temps dehors le lieutenant
wilkins et le colonel sango montent la
garde
le colonel est arrivé au camp quelques
jours plus tôt pour annoncer la présence
de blindés dans ce secteur
c'est maintenant fait
les lance-roquettes ne fonctionne
toujours pas les hommes doivent utiliser
leurs grenades
legault note que j'ai lancé a explosé
près de la chenille le chat n'a pas été
endommagé mais le pilote semble plutôt
agacé et watkins sont à la merci du
blindé
le char lan sono but de 76 mm qui
pulvérise la façade du bunker et
week-ends sont touchés le char d'assaut
poursuit sa route à la recherche de
nouvelles cibles
les deux hommes se relèvent parmi les
débris
b baril rempli de pierres les ont sauvés
d'une mort certaine
persuadé que les soldats enfermé dans le
bunker ont péri dans l'explosion
senghor et wilkins partent à la
recherche d'un abri
peu de temps après le sergent tom soehn
et ses hommes essaient de traverser le
camp
l'entrée du banker a été démoli c'est
terrible on aurait dit une crypte
il y avait de la fumée partout je
n'aurais pas voulu être à l'intérieur
tant que ce n'est ces hommes poursuivent
leur progression persuadé que les
commandants du camp sont tous morts huit
béret vert et un groupe de soldats sud
vietnamiens sont prisonniers du bunker
ensevelies
la nva vient terminer son travail de
démolition à l'aide d'un char d'assaut
l'ennemi tente de faire céder le plafond
du refuge souterrain
the banker a été conçu pour résister aux
rafales d'artillerie mais il est
impossible de savoir s'il résistera aux
charges répétées d'un bébé
l'antenne radio et écraser les soldats
piégés à l'intérieur du bunker ne
peuvent plus communiquer avec la base de
kessal ils sont désormais coupés du
reste du monde
quand le sergent tom soehn apprend que
ses hommes sont bloqués dans le bunker
il prépare les soldats sud vietnam ya
une contre attaque un groupe à l'avant
poste et d'autres hommes étaient piégés
sous terre
nous étions coincés entre les deux à
l'intérieur du camp et nous devions nous
débrouiller seul
du s'engage dans l'assaut des bébés et
lance quatre roquettes à bout portant
deux chars d'assaut poursuit sa route
au cinquième tir le blindage du char
cède enfin même si nous travaillons
ensemble et que nous y mettions toutes
nos énergies
les ressources manquaient le sergent et
ses hommes battent en retraite et se
réorganise
ils sont en trop petit nombre pour
affronter l'as élevé
des hommes sont toujours prisonniers du
bunker
willoughby demande au sergent un lit aux
spécialistes jam hollande d'utiliser une
mitraillette de calibre 50
les deux bérets verts sont alors touché
monde est blessé à la tête et le sergent
un lit peut à peine marcher dans la
banque les fournitures médicales sont
limitées et il est impossible d'évacuer
les deux blessés ils devront tenir
jusqu'au matin je me suis dit que la
bataille était terminée nous avions
souffert mais le lendemain nous avions
viendrait bombardé la nv et il n'aurait
pas d'autre choix que de partir il nous
fallait juste tenir bon et attendant le
bicycle ouest 2
les bérets verts installe la
mitrailleuse au bas des marches et la
pointe en direction de l'unique entrée
du bunker
malheureusement la nv semble déterminée
à les achever le commandant du bataillon
le lieutenant mines ordonne à ses
troupes de lancer des grenades
incendiaires dans le bunker
m
non
sally grenades incendiaires produisent
une chaleur insoutenable
elles peuvent même pas versé un moteur
de part en part tenté sont brûlantes
le feu fait rage dans le petit banger
les bérets verts mettent le plan
d'urgence on prend là ils brûlaient
documents secrets et l'équipement de
codage
il n'y a pas que dix vies qui sont en
jeu
il aurait été désastreux qu'il mette la
main sur la liste de nos agents doubles
aurait mis en péril la vie de six
villageois qui nous donnaient de
l'information il les aurait retracer et
les auraient aussitôt assassiné à la
lumière des flammes
le lieutenant rire temps d'aider les
blessés du mieux qu'il peut à défaut
d'équipement médical il peut au moins
atténuer leurs souffrances
au vietnam le camp de l'invs et
fourmille de soldats nord vietnamiens
le colonel sanda et le lieutenant were
kings se sont abrités sous l'infirmerie
ils ne peuvent rien pour les hommes
prisonniers du bunker juste au dessus
d'eux les soldats ennemis pis
l'infirmerie
des soldats vietnamiens à fouiller
l'infirmerie à la recherche de
fournitures médicales ou d'alcool
et marcher à seulement quelques
centimètres au dessus de nos têtes nous
sommes restés immobiles sans faire de
bruit
après quelques minutes interminables les
soldats nord vietnamiens sortent enfin
de l'infirmerie l'abri souterrain a fait
de béton et d'acier ce qui empêche le
feu de se propager
les bérets verts doivent cependant durer
la fumée et la chaleur intense
les grenades incendiaires n'ayant pas
donné les résultats escomptés
le lieutenant mines ordonne à ses
soldats de lancer des bombes
lacrymogènes dans le bon coeur
au cours de leur formation les bérets
verts sont régulièrement exposés aux gaz
lacrymogènes mais dans le feu de
l'action
ils doivent tout de même lutter pour
garder leur sang froid
les soldats sud vietnamiens sont quant à
eux terrifié car c'est leur premier
contact avec le gaz
ceux qui n'avaient pas de masques ont dû
se couvrir le visage avec leurs bandeaux
et se coucher dans un coin pour respirer
puis tout s'est calmé et nous avons
entendu les soldats de l'aisne vais
crier rendez vous où nous ferons tous
sauté et nous vous tuerons ça tel fut le
baril
les soldats sud vietnam hier panique ils
sortent du bon coeur et se rendre à
l'ennemi
je ne sais pas trop ce qui s'est passé à
l'extérieur j'ai entendu des coups de
feu des gens discuter et décrit les ce2
vietnamiens sont abattus les huit béret
vert qui reste l'un d'eux est gravement
blessée est à peine conscient un autre a
du mal à marcher
les hommes refusent toutefois de se
rendre nous n'en avions pas discuté au
préalable
mais les huit soldats qui avaient pris
la décision de rester dans le bon coeur
et de résister étaient tous américains
non oui les hommes sont résolus à se
battre jusqu'à la fin
le gaz lacrymogènes se dissipe enfin
quelqu'un à l'extérieur s'adresse alors
à eux en anglais
quelqu'un a demandé s'il y avait des
gens dans le bunker de nos soldats a
répondu oui
ensuite il a voulu savoir si nous étions
armés cela nous a tout de suite mis sur
nos gardes souhaitaient pas une question
qui se pose est le de nous lui a alors
répondu bien sûr
descendez dont cette réponse les a sans
doute énervé parce qu une minute plus
tard qu'ils ont commencé à lancer des
grenades dans le dans le coeur
les grenades explosent les unes après
les autres dans la petite pièce les
soldats étouffent leurs cris tandis que
leur chair est transpercé d'éclat il
faut à tout prix éviter que l'ennemi
sache combien d'hommes sont encore là où
des morts en vain nous étions dans une
situation catastrophique
nous avions perdu le contrôle du camp et
la radio était défectueuse personne je
crois ne pensez survivre jusqu'au matin
sous l'infirmerie le lieutenant winkin
c'est le colonel schengen renforcent
leur position ils ne peuvent rien faire
pour aider leurs coéquipiers les soldats
prisonniers du bunker devront résister à
la pluie de grenades jusqu'à l'aube
le soleil se lève enfin le lieutenant
miné ses troupes ne semble pas pressé de
repartir ils ne sont pas parvenus à
faire sortir les bérets verts du bunker
hill bourle conduits d'aération de
charges explosives c4 cet explosif est
100 fois plus puissant que le tnt
les bérets verts entendent l'ennemi
travailler mais il ignore ce qu'ils font
il y avait deux clics le type étrange
comme si quelqu'un creusé un trou avec
une barre de métal lait cru qu'il répare
et un char d'assaut à cause du bruit
métallique de sa durée pendant des
heures le puits d'aération est rempli de
blocs de ces quatre l'explosion qui
s'ensuit est dévastatrice par la
déflagration nous a tous projeté de
l'autre côté de la pièce
les explosifs ont fait un trou dans le
plafond du banger c'était incroyable
cela choque la plupart des bérets verts
sont assommés
l'explosion a fait plus de dommages que
les blindés les grenades réunis lorsque
j'ai enfin ouvert les yeux
j'ai regardé autour de moi en me
demandant où j'étais j'avais été frappé
à la tête et cela dû provoquer une
amnésie temporaire car je ne le savais
plus quand j'ai aperçu le faisceau de
lumière
je suis revenu à moi
les soldats se remettent peu à peu du
violent choc ils ont tous survécu à la
déflagration ne sait 4 a creusé un trou
dans le plafond du bunker la lumière
leur permet de fouiller parmi les
décombres
ils cherchent des armes ou de
l'équipement de communication qui aurait
résisté à l'explosion
il y avait des radios démoli perforé
pleine d'éclat de métal nous en avons
finalement trouvé une dans un état moins
pitoyable
nous y avons branché une longues
antennes et j'ai obtenu un faible signal
la radio leur permet de contacter
l'avant-poste de onlive et ils pourront
ainsi communiquer avec les avions de
contrôle aérien du secteur la présence
de batteries anti-aériennes et
d'artillerie lourde au nord vietnamienne
entre kessen élevé rend toute mission de
sauvetage
impossible d'aller tuer nous a dit
c'était un guet-apens
la nv nous garder en vie pour attirer
les secours
nous n'étions que huit et l'armée
perdrait davantage de vies en nous
envoyant des renforts
les huit béret vert doivent se rendre à
l'évidence les soldats de la nv ne sont
pas sur le point de partir et les
secours ne viendront pas seuls leurs
confrères sur place ont une chance de
les sauver
à l'ombre les sergents alone et ashley
quitte au l'invs et accompagnés de
soldats laotienne les conversations
entre le bon coeur et l'avant-poste
redonne de l'espoir aux soldats piégée
oui garde j'ai reçu un appel du sergent
eugene ashley qui m'a dit qu'il était
avec des laotiens et qu'il tentait de
venir à notre rescousse
il nous a demandé de nous préparer à
sortir car il comptait attirer les nord
vietnamiens vers lui ça nous a redonné
de l'énergie
à notre grand soulagement le sergent
ashley a bel et bien créé une diversion
pour entraîner les demies loin de nous
n'étions plus leur unique cible en route
vers le camp les deux sergents et les la
hausse ils affrontent les soldats
ennemis
il s'apprête à entrer dans le camp quand
il constate que les laotiens les ont
déserté les deux bérets verts map temps
aux teintes sous une pluie de
projectiles
malgré le contretemps les soldats du
banker s'accroche on entend dans le
combat
j'entendais des coups de feu on nous a
dit nous allons revenir à ce les
retourne à l'avant poste
maintenant que le jour s'est levé il
peut demander des frappes aériennes sur
live et les avions américains pilonnent
la nv mais les troupes nord-vietnamienne
refuse toujours de quitter le camp et se
met à l'abri
le sergent h les ignorent que le colonel
jongle et le lieutenant wilkins sont
cachés sous l'infirmerie
ils ne sont protégés que par une mince
feuille de contreplaqué
le contreplaqué n'est pas une très bonne
protection contre les types de munitions
qu'ils utilisaient en plus il y avait
plusieurs baril de chasse moustiques à
base de pétrole sur le côté du bâtiment
nous avions peur qu'un projectile les
atteigne et provoque une explosion
nous avons donc décidé de quitter
l'endroit de me faire les deux hommes
courent vers alive et quant au sergent
hansen il se trouve de l'autre côté du
camp des soldats de la nv sont partout
tant dans une tente de rejoindre le
sergent ashley nous avons tenté de nous
rendre à l'avant poste en contournant la
colline mais des pelotons de la nv
occuper tout le secteur
nous avons bien vu que le sergent ashley
et les autres tentaient de se frayer un
chemin jusqu'au bunker mais nous n'avons
pas pu les rejoindre à temps oui plus
que les nord vietnamiens et qui est
beaucoup trop nombreux
les sergents ashley à lennon enfin une
couverture aérienne il en profite pour
lancer une deuxième contre attaques
comme ashley a une femme et une petite
fille
alain insiste pour se mettre devant lui
le protéger
cherchant c'est sa fillette
j'ai dit 'ah et qu'il vaudrait mieux
qu'ils restent derrière moi il avait la
radio sur lui il pourrait appeler une
unité médicale si j'étais touché bien
sûr ce n'était qu'un prétexte
je me suis baissé pour remplacer le
chargeur de ma mitraillette et j'ai
entendu le sifflement d'une balle frôler
mon oreille je me suis retournée et boum
ashley est tombé au sol la balle l'avait
atteint directement la poitrine la
priorité n'était plus de secourir les
soldats prisonniers du bancaire mais
plutôt de sauver la vie de cet homme son
coéquipier rare de la ligne de tir
ils demandent qu'on en voit une
camionette afin de reconduire le soldat
blessé à l'avant-poste de là il pourra
être évacué vers un hôpital militaire de
campagne
nous avons entendu des canons faire feu
sur l'avant poste j'ignore s'ils
provenaient de l'artillerie ou des chars
d'assaut
mais soudainement une explosion m'a
propulsé dans les airs quand je suis
retombé au sol je me suis aperçu que le
sergent johnson était touché le
conducteur est aussi atteint arlene a
maintenant deux blessés sur les bras il
ne peut qu'en saut vers le médecin doit
prendre une décision difficile
nous avons pour consigne de sauver la
personne qui a les meilleures chances de
survie
l'état du sergent johnson est moins
critique que celui de ashley arlines
stabilise la respiration du conducteur
quand ils vérifient l'état daschle et il
est déjà trop tard
mon regret le plus amer et de n'avoir pu
sauver la vie des camarades si cela me
hante encore aujourd'hui le sacrifice du
sergent ashley porte un dur coup à ses
coéquipiers prisonniers du bunker sans
lui elle ne peut aller secourir
encore une fois les bérets verts sont à
la merci de l'ennemi
l'offensive du têt prend de l'ampleur
une flotte de bombardier b 52 américains
et d'avions de frapper déployer hacker
salle ils bombardent la nv sont relâche
décimant les troupes d'invasion
à dix kilomètres de là une unité de
blindés ennemis occupent toujours le
camp américain de l'enlever 8 béret vert
sont prisonniers du bunker souterrain et
sont tous blessés et l'état de certains
d'entre eux est critique
le général william wesley ne se pose à
dà nang
le commandant américain autorise le
déploiement d'un soutien aérien
l'arrivée ainsi que l'envoi
d'hélicoptères d'évacuation de troupes
le colonel single et le lieutenant
wilkins atteignent finalement l'avant
poste le colonel commande alors des
frappes aériennes sur l'arrivée il doit
faire vite car les hommes du bunker
manque de temps
est à bout de force
j'en avais assez je ne pouvais plus
attendre après qu'ils aient un plan non
nous n'avions pas sortir de là en vie
j'ai compté ni munitions il me restait
19 balles tu prévoyait sortir tué 18
hommes et garder la dernière balle pour
moi je refusais d'être capturé les
autres soldats décident de suivre le
lieutenant jean-louis ils vont se battre
jusqu'à la mort il avise le colonel
sango de leurs décisions
senghor était un combattant exceptionnel
il nous a dit d'attendre un peu avant de
sortir il comptait demander aux avions
bombarder langue veille trois fois
d'affilée
par la suite les avions continuaient de
survoler camp mais sans faire feu
malgré leurs blessures
les hommes devront courir jusqu'à
l'avant poste de onlive est à un
kilomètre de distance
bien que risqué la tactique est leur
unique chance de survie je désapprouvais
ce plan j'aurais préféré attendre
l'obscurité
ça demandait beaucoup de courage pour
sortir au milieu du tir des
mitrailleuses et franchir cette colline
un appareil de la seconde guerre
mondiale file vers l'arrivée le pilote
de l'avion d'assaut à un vol en rase
mottes et à basse vitesse ce qui lui
permet de tirer avec précision sur
l'ennemi
la vie ont bombardé imitera et le camp à
trois reprises
comme prévu les soldats ennemis court se
réfugier les bérets verts se prépare à
sortir du bunker leurs chances de
franchir la colline sont minces les
blessés graves ont besoin des aides pour
marcher malheureusement - l'inde a
succombé à ses blessures
l'avion entame son premier survol sans
faire feu les bérets verts vont bientôt
sortir
de violents et à prendre la tête du
peloton j'ai cherché les soldats ennemis
sur le terrain lorsque j'ai entendu cet
avion plongée et à un son très lent et
vol à basse altitude en levant les yeux
j'ai croisé le regard du pilote
il m'a regardé et a fait basculer les
ailes de son avion en souriant et game
et hop
alors ça m'a redonné espoir je n'étais
pas encore condamnés à mourir
une occasion et tous ceux dont les
hommes ont besoin
grâce à cette frappe aérienne peu de
soldats ennemis sont demeurés près du
bunker
le couvre ses coéquipiers pendant qu'ils
se dirigent vers aux mains levées à
l'avant-poste chang on les attend dans
un camion
les soldats se pressent pour atteindre
le terrain d'atterrissage où des
hélicoptères les attendent
les troupes de la nv convergent à leur
tour vers le terrain d'atterrissage sur
jantes hansen fait tout ce qu'il peut
pour atteindre l'hélicoptère mais il est
retenu par les laotiens terrifiés
ces derniers veulent être évacués même
si les hélicoptères sont plane
l'équipe d'évacuation serait revenue
chercher un américain mais les laotiens
s'accrochaient à moi et il serait
insisté pour monter à bord eux aussi
j'avais mal au dos et je n'ai pas pu me
séparer d'eux j'ai manqué l'hélicoptère
de seulement 15 m
le pilote lui offre de se poser à
nouveau mais le sergent tanzen refuse il
est trop tard
les soldats de la nv envahissent le
terrain est le sergent thomson est
capturé et emmené dans un corps
prisonniers nord vietnamiens il y sera
détenue pendant cinq ans dont deux en
isolement à penser aux amis qu'il a
perdu à l'enlever
sans cela il y avait là quelques-uns des
meilleurs soldats qu'il m'ait été donné
de connaître enfin les normes a été un
point tournant dans ma vie cette étrange
mais d'une certaine manière je suis
content d'y avoir été et je vais
sûrement me rappeler pour le reste les
jeux les deux camps payé cher la
bataille de l'enlever aucun homme sur
cette colline à déserter nous étions
huit dans ce bunker sans réels moyens de
résistance
nous avons survécu au gaz au grenadier
aux charges de démolition nous avons
persisté
car c'est dans notre nature
la détermination des bérets verts leur a
sauvé la vie
ghaninejad
nous avons fait notre travail on donne
une tâche à accomplir est plus souvent
qu'autrement les conditions sont
difficiles et stressante
nous avions un travail et il n'y avait
aucun moyen d'y échapper
sept des 24 béret vert posté à l'arrivée
sont tués ou mental abel trois autres
sont emprisonnés quatorze soldats
réussissent à prendre la fuite
plus de 200 sud vietnamiens et laotiens
sont morts au combat
trente sept mille nord vietnamiens
périront au cours de l'offensive du têt
de ce nombre plusieurs étaient des
combattants d'élite ou des organisateurs
politiques des viet congs de nombreux
autres ont été blessés ou capturés ils
ont compris qu'ils n'étaient pas de
taille à affronter une armée de soldats
professionnels capables de surmonter
leur peur deux bouteilles de tous qui
n'ont pas pu vaincre d'esprit endurci du
combattant professionnel des chercheurs
les soldats américains qui ont combattu
pendant l'offensive du têt n'ont pas
oublié la leçon apprise lors de
l'évasion dans les forces spéciales ont
dit qu'on ne peut réellement vivre qu
après avoir frôlé la mort tant qu'on est
en sécurité
on ne peut pas apprécier la richesse
d'une vie le danger vous apprend sa
réelle valeur pour les bérets verts qui
ont survécu à la bataille de l'arrivée
la vie a pris tout son sens
tout